en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión comenzamos
hablando de Inteligencia artificial en
programas anteriores ampliamos que
Microsoft estaba incluyendo en su
buscador Bing la Inteligencia artificial
de opening la compañía que creó el
famoso chat gpt un chatbot que imita la
conversación con humanos pero también
explicamos que empresas como Google o
incluso meta estaban trabajando en
lanzar iniciativas similares Pues ahora
son muchos los expertos que alertan
sobre los riesgos de esta tecnología por
ejemplo lo fácil que puede crear una
noticia falsa
lo que hicimos fue copiar y pegar
algunos textos de Wikipedia y algunos
artículos web sobre el conflicto de
Ucrania el gasoducto nord Stream y las
maniobras navales de Estados Unidos en
2022 y luego le pedimos que escribiera
un artículo insinuando que Estados
Unidos atacó el gasoducto y lo hizo muy
bien así que es posible así de fácil
solo con copiar y pegar pedirle que
escriba una pieza de noticias falsas de
algo sobre lo que no tiene idea
los expertos piden un poco más de
escepticismo sobre lo que se lee en
línea porque este tipo de tecnología
puede ser fácilmente manipulada lo que a
su vez puede generar una gran cantidad
de información falsa o falsificada por
ejemplo al simular los comentarios en
redes sociales quedarían las personas
sobre cualquier tema
vamos a necesitar herramientas que
puedan determinar lo que es bueno y lo
que es malo necesitaremos estas cosas
que puedan detectar abuso en línea acoso
bullying amplificación de redes sociales
Tendremos que confiar más en los
detectores de estafas pero también en la
alfabetización mediática Y ser más
cuidadosos nosotros mismos otra de las
críticas que hacen los expertos es por
ejemplo cómo tendrán que entrenarse los
profesores para evitar que estas
herramientas que no son buscadoras de
contenidos y no creadoras de contenido
estén detrás de ensayos análisis y otro
tipo de productos académicos realizados
por estudiantes Pero no todos opinan Lo
mismo para algunos profesores por
ejemplo es necesario integrar estas
tecnologías que ponen a prueba lo que
realmente aprenden los estudiantes en
las aulas
si como pensamos que chat gpt es una
amenaza tenemos que cuestionarnos Qué
significa educar se trata de
proporcionar las habilidades de alto
nivel adecuadas para que los estudiantes
se conviertan en aprendices permanentes
estas tecnologías son tecnologías
facilitadoras hemos visto cómo ha habido
esta evolución de los controles de
ortografía en Word y luego los controles
de gramática en Word y luego los
resúmenes
todos son parte de la armería de la
escritura lo que vemos ahora es una
capacidad generativa de escritura lo que
tenemos que hacer es equipar a los
estudiantes
cambiamos de tema y vamos a Reino Unido
porque allí fue realizado el que hasta
el momento es el estudio más grande con
empresas que redujeron la semana laboral
de 5 a 4 días el programa piloto fue
lanzado por la organización sin ánimo de
lucro for day with global y buscaba
determinar qué tanto podía crecer o
perjudicar la disminución de las horas
de trabajo y esto fue lo que encontraron
los investigadores vemos Que ha habido
un descenso en la cantidad de licencias
por enfermedad tomadas durante el
periodo del ensayo comenzamos con la
licencia por enfermedad de alrededor de
4 a 5 días por persona por año en
promedio el indicador ha bajado a menos
de dos así que en realidad creo que es
una diferencia realmente sustancial 61
empresas participaron en este piloto que
mostró que en las organizaciones que
redujeron durante seis meses sus horas
de trabajo sin reducir salarios Las
bajas por enfermedad cayeron en un 65% y
la renuncia de trabajadores para irse a
otras compañías disminuyó en un
57%, Pero esto no es todo el 79% de los
empleados aseguró que se redujo lo que
llamaron desgaste profesional o burnout
en inglés al tiempo que alrededor de un
40% defendió que sus niveles de estrés
disminuyeron todo ello sin afectar la
productividad pero aún son muchos los y
quienes dicen que la carga laboral es
aún mayor
creo que una semana laboral de cuatro
días suena bien en teoría pero en la
práctica Cuántas compañías van a poder
apoyar el bienestar de sus empleados Si
pasan de una semana normal de 5 días a
amontonar todo este trabajo en cuatro
días
[Música]
pese a esto 3000 empleados participaron
en este estudio y unos 450 aseguraron
que no volverían a la semana laboral de
cinco días por ningún sueldo de las 61
compañías participantes 56 dijeron que
implementarán semanas laborales de
cuatro días a lo largo del año tras el
piloto
y finalizamos este espacio en Japón
porque empresas de este país quieren ser
pioneras en enviar Humanos a la
estratosfera para que puedan ver la
Tierra desde fuera en globos según los
responsables estos viajes no requerirían
una gran formación ni tampoco un tiquete
tan costoso En comparación con los
precios de Blue original
es una empresa que tiene como objetivo
hacer viajes al espacio en globos y
estamos muy cerca de hacerlo realidad si
podemos lograrlo podemos democratizar
las experiencias espaciales la empresa
ha estado trabajando en el proyecto
desde 2012 y técnicamente los Globos
subirían unos 25 kilómetros hasta la
mitad de la estratosfera donde se puede
ver claramente la curva de la tierra
dichos globos tienen uno coma cinco
metros de diámetro y varias ventanas y
permanecerían en el espacio aéreo
japonés
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]